FEMALE SPEAKER: All
right, everyone.
Thank you so much for joining us
for this edition of our Authors
at Google talk with Audrey Lee.
We're excited to
have Audrey here
to discuss her new book,
which she co-authored
with Jane Hyun, "Flex",
the new playbook
for managing across differences.
So who is Audrey?
Audrey S. Lee is an executive
coach and global leadership
and diversity strategist who
consults with Fortune 500
companies to develop
integrated leadership
strategies that impact
business practices
throughout organizations.
She expertly combines program
facilitation, coaching,
and leadership
consulting practice
with more than 13
years of experience
in marketing communications,
product and program strategy,
alliance and channel marketing.
So we decided to
bring Audrey here
to Google because of
her vast experience,
and also because
Google is committed
to bringing people together in
our workforce, our industry,
and on the web, who have a
broad range of attributes,
experiences and points of view.
We believe our differences
make us stronger,
and produce better,
more innovative work.
We recognize, though,
that we're not
where we want to be when it
comes to diversity, especially
in tech and leadership.
And that's where
"Flex" comes in.
The book expounds
on the vital skill
of flexing, the art of switching
between leadership styles
to more effectively
work with people
who are different than you.
This critical skill
allows managers
to navigate successfully
the diverse business
environment of
today and tomorrow.
So with no further ado, I'd
like to invite Audrey up
to the stage.
AUDREY S. LEE:
Thank you so much.
I'm really grateful to
have this opportunity
to come to Google
here in Mountain View.
And I just wanted to say
that I started my career
and worked out here in
Silicon Valley for 12 years
before moving to New York City
and making that my current home
and starting my work in
leadership development.
So I'm really
grateful to be back,
and I just-- I remember
Silicon Valley when
237 was a two-lane highway
and the biggest thing
here in Mountain View was
Shoreline Ampitheater.
So it's changed a lot.
I'm grateful to be here, and
I really thank the [INAUDIBLE]
for inviting me to talk a
little bit about Asian diversity
and leadership
development here at Google
and in this conversation.
I just wanted to start
out by telling you
a little bit about myself.
I am a first-generation
Asian-- American-born Chinese.
My parents immigrated from China
here in the late '50s and '60s,
and I was born here in the
United States and raised here.
So I have lots of stories
and a lot of experience that
crosses cultures, because
I grew up very bicultural.
My father was very
Chinese, and my parents
had very strong Confucian values
which they instilled in us.
There was no English
spoken at home.
We ate only Chinese food.
And one of my first bicultural
navigating experiences
happened when I was very young,
in elementary school, when
I went to school with my
lunch and a tupperware
with rice and some
soy sauce chicken.
It's delicious, because
my mom was a great cook.
But as I sat down for
lunch, I realized that when
my friends took out their brown
bags with their peanut butter
and jelly and their
bologna sandwiches
with Fritos, that
I basically had
a lunch that was not tradable.
So I had completely
destroyed my social capital.
Nobody wanted
anything that I had.
And in elementary school,
that's a really big deal.
All of a sudden you
find yourself not quite
fitting in with a group.
I have to say that my father's
Confucian values kind of went
a little bit deeper
than just food
and language and
that type of thing.
And his values were especially
pronounced and especially deep
in the area of
authority and humility,
and how the different roles in
the family-- as the youngest
girl the family--
the different roles
that you played in the family.
And what that meant
in our family,
with the respect for authority,
was that my dad was king.
You did not question him,
you did not challenge him.
You didn't look at him wrong.
Certainly not with any
direct eye contact.
He also made it very clear
that my sister and I were not
to talk about our
accomplishments.
So we weren't to talk
about how well we did.
And I have a distinct
memory of coming back home
one day after doing particularly
well on an assignment
and getting praise from
my peers and my teacher
and saying-- I was so excited,
I did great on this project.
And he looked at me and
really frowned and said,
really adamantly, "that
is not for you to say".
It is not for you to say
that you did a good job.
You let your teacher tell
you that you did a good job.
And then don't say
anything about that.
Don't even really accept it.
Because they will
tell you when you're
doing a good job, and
that is your role.
And that's what humility
looked like from my father.
And I know for some
of you-- some of you
are nodding with this
experience-- and some of you
might be thinking, wow,
that's really foreign
or that's really harsh,
that he would do that.
But for my father,
his value of humility
was so strong that he really
wanted to instill that in us.
And that's what humility
looked like to him.
Don't talk about yourself.
Don't ever do that.
And it's the role
of the person who's
in authority, or the teacher,
to tell you what you're worth.
So fast forward about 15 years.
I'd started my
career in technology.
I thought I was doing pretty.
I was able to initiate a
lot of my career direction.
I really loved
networking, and I thought
I was doing pretty well
in starting my career.
And every once in
awhile, I would
have a moment where I felt
like I brought the wrong lunch.
Where sometimes my
values didn't quite
match up with the
environment around me,
or I wasn't
communicating in a way
that everyone else
was communicating.
Maybe I was a little
bit different.
But I couldn't really
put my finger on it
until I started my own
marketing practice,
about six to seven
years into my career.
And that's where I had an "aha"
moment about how my values
and how my cultural
background really
impacted how I behaved
in the workplace.
I had just started my
marketing practice,
and I was starting
to put out proposals
and talking to
prospective clients.
And in doing that,
I discovered I
had to put a dollar sign behind
my experience and my expertise.
And not only that,
I had to defend it.
And I remember being in
front of my future client
and talking about the proposal
and getting to that line item
and having him start
negotiating with me.
And then I thought,
at that moment,
I realized I had
never in my career
talked about my value
in terms of my salary.
I had never asked for a raise.
I had never asked
for a promotion.
Whenever I got a feedback
or performance review,
I just listened
to what was said.
Positive, constructive, and sort
of tried to run out of the room
quickly, because
it was something
that I was just going to accept.
I was going to accept any
salary raise that I got,
because who would know better
than my boss what I was worth.
So I learned that
that was not my job
to ascribe value to who I was.
I was perfectly happy
with that until I
started my own business.
And it was in that moment
that I learned I actually
had to play by a
different set of rules.
But I could still--
I had to think
through what my values were
with respect for authority,
with humility, and
decide how I was
going to act in that situation.
Because the person I was talking
to expected me to negotiate.
They expected me to know my
own value and to defend it.
And that was the
exchange I was having.
And in that moment I realized
that I had to do a little bit
to adapt to my environment,
and to understanding
what that played in my career.
This incident and many others
early in my career really
started me on this long journey
of doing some deep digging,
deep soul searching,
and really finding out
what was in my background.
Really what was
underneath the surface
that really impacted
how I communicated,
how I came across,
and ultimately
what perceptions were out
there about me in the workplace
where my career
decisions really mattered
and people were making judgments
on me based on what they saw.
I think that might be
true for some of you,
that sometimes when you go
out there, if you are perhaps
different than the dominant
culture of your team
or the organization, you might
maybe feel a little bit out
of place, or maybe
you fall outside
of the old boys' network.
You might be communicating
a little bit different.
You might feel that.
And what do you do
if you're different
from the dominant culture?
And maybe those
who are listening
who are in the
dominant culture, what
do you do when you see
or you experience someone
who is different than you?
Who leads different than you?
Who communicates
different than you?
Who maybe seems to be exhibiting
behaviors that aren't what
you would consider
leadership potential.
What do you do in
those situations?
And what do we all do to move
the conversation of diversity
just beyond a sectioned-off
department that
talks about differences
into the realm of management
and leadership development.
So that's what I really
want to talk about,
is the changing landscape of
our workforce and our talent
and our environment.
How it's changing here
in the United States,
and how that affects us,
because I think a lot of you
also have global
roles in addition
to perhaps working with a
lot of diverse team members.
So let's take a quick look just
through some of the numbers.
We won't dwell too much
on this, but women now
make up about half
of the workforce,
and they hold about 70 percent
of global buying decisions.
Multiculturalists as a group,
36 percent of the labor force,
$3.3 trillion dollars
in buying power.
And millennials, the new
generation, 80 million
millennials comprising 46
percent of the labor force
by 2020.
And they also hold $1.3 trillion
dollars in buying power.
And there's quite
a bit of research
that shows companies who
have diverse leadership
and workforces really have
a higher profitability
and increasing bottom line.
A recent Catalyst
report shows that there
is an increase in
sales by 73 percent,
and 83 percent return
on equity for companies
that had diverse board
and executive committees.
Usually they were
doing a study on having
women in those
executive positions.
So we see that we have
this changing landscape.
We have a changing workforce.
They actually have
quite a bit of influence
on both our companies
and the market.
It's quite a bit of power.
How do we leverage this?
And as we look at the
numbers, the workforce
is so different than when I
first started my career back
in the '90s.
And it's really
grown to present.
And in 2050, we're going
to see that there's
no majority culture.
With the fastest-growing
population
being Latinos, and
currently in 2012,
Asians and Asian Americans
are the fastest-growing ethnic
group here in the United States.
And of course, Google-- just to
take a look at Google numbers--
how do they compare
against the growth
of the diverse
population in the States?
And I know you are very
familiar with these numbers
and what they mean, and
articles that have come out
about it over the
last number of weeks,
and sort of where
the opportunities are
to grow for women, as well as
African Americans and Latinos.
I've have quite a
number of conversations
with people about
these Asian numbers.
Because they look fantastic.
And I'm going to show you
sort of the numbers overall
for the rest the United States
as far as how Asians are doing.
But with Asians being 30
percent of Google globally
and 23 percent of leadership,
that looks like it's great.
So where do we go
from here, and what
are some of the questions
that arise from that?
Some of the questions that I
would have been in conversation
with Googlers is, these
are global numbers.
What's the percentage of Asian
Americans here in the States
that are in leadership,
that are part of this, that
are part of the
fabric of Google?
And how many are
people who are here
who might be H1 visa holders?
What are the other
barriers that are presented
to Asian Americans in
their actual experience?
So I would be very
interested to continue
the conversation
with Google to see
what is the experience of
Asian Americans here Google.
What kind of engagement
issues, what kind of barriers
are people facing here,
are Googlers facing here,
that they need to talk
about, that they need
to verbalize and take a look at.
And as we look at that, we can
really look at the real issues
that impact the work,
as well as the numbers.
Because the numbers are a
really great place to start,
but we have to move beyond
the numbers in representation
when we look at that.
So Asian Americans.
Where are we now?
When we first started this work
with a lot of Asian Americans
and diversity back
in 2000, the numbers
were Asian Americans were
4.2 percent of population.
Now were 5.6 percent
of the population,
been the fastest-growing
ethnic group in the States.
Interestingly enough, 1.2
percent of Fortune 500 CEOs
are Asian.
And now we're at 1.8.
But that's actually fallen.
In 2011, we had 15 Asian
CEOs, and now we have 10.
The trend is actually for
African American, Asian
American, as well as
Latinos, the trend
is that there actually
has been a decreasing
number of CEOs in
the last five years.
So that's an
interesting statistic.
Corporate boards, we now
hold 2 percent of that.
We have a really high
rate of college graduates
in the Asian
population, as well as
median income, which translates
to buying power in the market.
So currently we're at more than
$1 trillion in buying power.
So that's kind of where we are.
We have a great deal of
influence in the market.
We are very educated.
We're ready to go.
But the numbers are not
being reflected, really,
in leadership.
So that's our story.
We're getting in the door.
And I'm hearing again and again
that we go through our careers
and somehow there's this
ceiling that happens,
and we're not necessarily
advancing into the leadership
positions and
positions of influence.
And that really affects,
I think, the way
we are seen in the workplace.
And there are a lot of
stories that are out there.
So I just wanted to
take a quick look
at some of these stories
that are out there.
Some of these narratives
that are out there that
are being told about Asians.
Let me just start
with this first one.
Asians don't really want to be
in top leadership and executive
roles.
What do you think?
Is that a myth or a fact?
What do you think about that?
It's a fact.
Well actually we had a little
conversation about this
at lunch time, because
there are actually--
when I talk to Asians, I
get different responses
about their career aspirations.
But this is actually a myth that
is quite prevalent out there.
When managers talk about
Asians and Asian Americans
and their career aspiration,
what I hear a lot is,
I don't hear from them.
They don't tell me, "I want
that stretch assignment".
Or they didn't tell me
they wanted that new role
or that their aspiration
is to make partner.
They didn't say that.
There's an interesting study
that came out from the Center
for Talent Innovation in New
York City headed by Sylvia Ann
Hewlett.
And this study talks
about Asians in America.
They interviewed 3,000
people nationwide,
and they talk to Asians
and Asian Americans
about their careers.
And what's interesting
is that 64 percent
of Asian professionals said
that they wanted top jobs.
And it was greater
than the number
of Caucasian professionals
that also expressed
the same kind of
aspirations for top jobs.
So it's not that Asians don't
want to be in leadership.
If that's the myth, that's the
perception, it's just not true.
And of course, I don't know
those numbers for Google,
but I would suspect that Asian
Americans and Asians really
want to get ahead, and there may
be this myth that they don't.
The other statistic
that's very interesting
is that 63 percent of Asian
men, 44 percent of Asian women,
feel stalled in their careers.
And 19 percent of Asian men
and 14 percent of Asian women
plan to leave their company
within the next year.
So organizations are faced--
and they should be afraid
that they're going to lose some
of their best talent because
of disengagement.
In a Gallup survey, they found
that about $450 billion to $550
billion is what is lost
by companies from employee
disengagement every year.
So if you lose an employee,
you can't retain them,
they don't stay engaged, they're
not going to be in a place
where they can actually
feel like they're
bringing themselves to work.
It's not going to work out
for retaining that employee.
It's costing companies
a lot of money.
What do you think
about this statement?
It's best to be "color-blind"
and not really important
to focus on differences
in the workplace.
After all, it's
just about respect
and treating everyone the same.
Treating everyone fairly.
What do you think
about that statement?
No?
Any comments about that?
Have you heard that
statement going around?
Great to be colorblind?
We're a post-racial
society, right?
We have Obama in the office.
There are no barriers
anymore, right?
What's interesting
about this statement is
there are a lot of people who
do think this is a great thing,
to be color blind or to
not notice differences,
because it sounds like, if
we don't notice differences
and we don't have
to talk about them,
there won't be any conflict.
We can just appeal to the
universal values of fairness
and respect, and
everything will be good.
But actually, what
we can't get beyond
is unconscious, inherent
biases that we all
have toward each other,
and the judgments
that actually are reached
even without us realizing it.
I was reading about
Laszlo Bock and engaging
Doctor Brian Wells here Google
to do quite a number of studies
on unconscious bias and
what they discovered.
There's also a number of studies
done by Harvard Business School
and Doctor [INAUDIBLE]
and University of Virginia
that talk about
unconscious bias,
where they've actually
found that people--
as an example of one of the
tests that they've done,
they had a list of positive
traits, positive adjectives,
and people actually correlated
that with Caucasians.
Caucasian people.
Caucasian faces.
And then they gave people
a list of negative traits
and negative
adjectives, and those
were more likely
to be correlated
with African American
and minority faces.
And those correlations
show those kind of biases.
So really I think
when-- Doctor Wells,
it was reported when he started
doing this work with Google,
he also found that there was
a systemic bias against women.
And that's why
women have not risen
to the ranks of leadership.
So it's a very interesting
thing to see how bias works out.
And also dangerous is the idea
of color blindness itself.
Because why do we want
to not see differences?
Differences are actually
what brings that innovation
and, ultimately, productivity
into the companies.
Into your teams.
Into the work that you do.
And what's interesting
is another study
that was done at
Harvard talks about how,
when you get a team
together that's diverse,
the team actually is
chaotic and full of conflict
and actually very
unproductive when they first
start working together.
And the only thing
that will help
that team become
productive and innovative
is if the leader of that team
and the people in the team
understand how to integrate and
recognize their differences,
and appreciate how that
adds value to the team.
There's actually a lot
of skills and training
that needs to happen
before you get
all these different opinions
and different backgrounds
into a room, and styles, before
it can become productive.
So the argument
that, oh we just need
to treat everybody the same, and
just to sort of lump leadership
development into
this general category
and hope that we
will get it, actually
doesn't go with how
we're hardwired.
Because we are actually--
neuroscientists
and behavioral
scientists, they really
have done a lot
of studies to say,
when we see someone different
than us, we run away
or we get really defensive.
Because if there's something
unknown and unfamiliar,
we're not going
to flock to that.
And we see that
that's especially
dangerous in this
homosocio phenomenon
where we like people
who are like us.
Which means in the workplace,
we hire people who look like us,
we promote people
who look like us,
and we gravitate
toward people, when
we're thinking about
mentoring, who look like us.
I can't tell you the number
of times I've actually
heard people say, oh
I've met this person
and I can't wait to start
mentoring them and coaching
them.
They're just like me!
I've got a mini-me,
and we're going
to have a whole
team of mini-mes.
People act so excited
when they find
that, they find someone
who's just like them.
And that is a natural tendency.
So when we start looking
at these natural tendencies
that we all have, what
do we do about them?
Unconscious bias.
And speaking of bias,
I think this is really
an interesting-- one of the
latest studies in talking
about the ceiling for
Asians and Asian Americans
has just come out.
And let's take a look
at this myth or fact.
If Asians just developed more
assertive leadership styles,
they would advance
in their careers.
What do you think
of that statement?
Have you heard that before?
Yeah?
So it seems true, right?
And we want to
believe it's true.
If we just acted
more like leaders,
it would be great
for our careers.
But I want to say
what's interesting is,
the University of Toronto
released a study in 2012 that
talks about how the bias is
so strong that they found
that East Asian leaders that
behaved with a dominant style--
if they were warm, if
they were personable,
and if they had a
very strong style,
they were actually disliked more
than any other style of people.
So people would actually
like and would rather
work with an East Asian
who is non-dominant
or a Caucasian who is
dominant or non-dominant.
And the stereotype, explicit
stereotype, that they tested
was that East Asians
were cold, they
were competent, extremely
so, and non-dominant.
And the expectation
of East Asians
was that they stay
in their place.
They stay in their place.
And when Asians behaved
outside of these stereotypes,
they were harassed for it, or
they were seen unfavorably.
So I looked at the results
of the study and I thought,
what do we do about this myth?
What do we do about
this, because we're
being asked to behave more
assertively, but what we do,
we're disliked.
And that also works against us.
So I have to say,
when I saw this,
I thought, organizations
and upper management
and people who are really
guiding and mentoring
and hiring and promoting people
within their organizations,
really need to take a look
at their unconscious bias.
We really need to change
how we see leadership
and the leadership styles
that are out there,
when we see people acting
outside of stereotype
trying to better their
leadership development
and really think, how are
we going to start working?
What do Asians do about this?
I think it's really
an art to do--
we're going to start talking
a little bit about flexing
and what we can do
in these situations--
to actually change this.
Because these are
narratives are happening.
These are stories about
Asians and Asian Americans
that are out there that
we have to confront.
I think maybe some
of you have heard
these stories, these narratives
about Asian Americans.
They're about Asian
Americans, but they're not
by Asian Americans.
So we have someone--
we have people
out there telling these
stories about us, about Asians,
and not necessarily
having our input to get
the full fabric, the
full story of us.
The first one is the
model minority myth.
How many have heard of
the model minority myth?
In the 1960s, sociologists wrote
about Asians-- specifically,
at the time, Japanese
Americans-- being
the model minority
immigrants that
came to the States
who did really well.
And they sort of pitted
that story, that narrative,
against other minority groups.
Because the thought was,
they came, they did it,
so there's no barrier.
So if you're not making it,
it's probably your fault.
It doesn't have anything
to do with the system.
And the idea is,
it also invalidated
a lot of what Asians
and Asian Americans
have to say about
their own experience,
about quote unquote what
their experience was
making it and actually
working in the United States.
So that is also a
myth because it's not
even true for all Asians.
There's a 13 percent
poverty rate for Asians,
in the different groups
of Asians, as well.
So they're not all
experiencing this huge success
that everyone is
talking about as we
think about the
model minority myth.
So it's very incomplete
when we look at that.
Also the perpetual
foreigner syndrome.
The same implicit
bias test that was
created by Doctor
[INAUDIBLE] at Harvard
showed a test where a
bunch of celebrities
were shown flashed
on the screen,
flashed in front of the
participants, the test takers.
And celebrities like Michael
Chang, Kristie Yamaguchi,
they were identified
as foreigners,
while Hugh Grant,
and Katarina Witt
were identified as Americans.
And they're not Americans.
But it was clear that the
bias for Asians-- they
didn't necessarily see Asians
as people from America.
And I have to say that
my own experiences would
echo that, even though I'm
shocked every time it happens.
Earlier this year with at
JFK, New York City airport.
And I was sitting there in
line and someone approached me
and said, hey are
you going to Hawaii?
I said, no, I'm not
going to Hawaii.
Why do you ask that?
Because I didn't
have any indicators
that I was going to Hawaii.
And he said, oh,
because there are
a lot of people who
look like you there.
And I thought wow.
OK.
Well there are a lot of people
who look like me here, too.
So this bias, I
think you thought
you might have had
experiences like this.
What it really is, including
all the stereotypical behaviors
that might be associated with
a lot of Asian Americans,
these narratives that are
about us really add up
to a question about
not just the fact
that Asians aren't in the
numbers for leadership--
and are Asians
leaders-- but do Asians
have leadership potential?
Are they ready for leadership?
Are they ready to be part
of the influential voice
of organizations and causes.
And that's why I
think that we have
to take a look at
these narratives.
We really have to
look at them and say,
what is our voice in this?
What is our narrative?
When we're putting it out
there, the more narratives
and the more stories we
have about our background
and how we approach
our careers, how
we approach leadership,
how we approach our work--
the more that gets out
there, the more people
will start seeing
and having options
to understand what
the full picture is.
One of the models I've found
very helpful in my work
is, when we talk about culture,
we look at the iceberg.
Iceberg, 1/10 of it
is above the surface.
And what does someone see
when they first meet you?
What do they
experience about you?
Language.
Your dress, maybe.
What you eat.
Behavior.
The way you talk.
All of those things
are above the surface.
But there is a full
9/10 below the surface
that people do not see.
When people saw me eat
my Chinese food at lunch,
they didn't necessarily ask me
all of the cultural elements
and values and things
that came with that.
They just saw what I was
doing on the surface.
So it's really important
that we understand
how to get beneath
the surface when
we have this conversation
of difference.
And sometimes it's
helpful for us
to know how to get
beneath the surface,
because what's
underneath the surface
are those cultural values
and things that I call,
basically, part of your core.
Your personality.
Your expertise.
Your years of experience
that really play into it
and influence ultimately
your behavior.
And then perception.
And as you unpack
that, you can start
to see, what's my own narrative?
What are my values that
drive what people see,
and what perception
is happening?
And so when you
start unpacking that,
it's interesting because-- let's
take the value of humility,
which is a very, very strong
Asian Confucian value.
If that is a very strong
value that I have,
the action might be that I don't
talk about my accomplishments.
That might be what
humility looks like to me.
But the perception I'm hoping
is that people think I'm humble.
Because I'm so humble, right?
But the perception
in a Western culture
isn't that you're humble, it's
that you don't have confidence
and that you don't know
how to talk about yourself.
Maybe you're not
even a contributor,
and you don't even
have that expertise.
So the perception is
completely different than what
I hope to project out there.
And when I take a
look at this equation
and I look at the
dynamics of this,
I have to ask myself--
is there a way that I
can keep who I am, with
my value of humility,
and have it look different
on the action side
but still retain
my value so that I
can manage that perception?
Because I want people to
experience me in a certain way,
is there a way I could talk
about myself in a humble way
and still keep my values?
And that's really the
opportunity, I think,
is for us to look at
the values that we have.
And for Asians,
traditionally Asian values
are respect for
authority-- we really
look at authority
in a way that we
like to keep the distance
because that means we respect
them, so oftentimes we
don't speak up in meetings
when our boss is
there, and sometimes
we may not talk
about who we are,
talk about accomplishments,
as I mentioned.
Humility is a great
example of a value.
Collectivism.
We don't necessarily
think in terms of "I."
We think in terms of "we."
So when we talk about
our accomplishments,
maybe we talk about what we
did instead of what I did.
And if we're in a very
individualistic environment--
as America and Western
corporations are
very individualistic--
we might butt heads
with people who had different
values, who see that, wow, you
didn't talk about yourself.
You used the word "we".
You don't talk about
your accomplishments,
and you're not
necessarily standing out.
And they see you as someone
who's not remarkable.
You don't stand
out in the crowd.
But you think you're
behaving in a way that
is very successful for
how you were raised.
Other values that play into
very traditional Asian values
are saving face.
A lot of indirect communication.
And the idea of fate.
Long suffering.
If you're seeing a
barrier or you're
going through a
really hard time,
you don't necessarily raise your
hand and be the squeaky wheel.
You're going to just sort of
hunker down, put your head
down, and get through it.
And that might be
how you deal with it.
And the way other
people perceive
you may be just
that you don't know
how to speak up for yourself.
You don't initiate change.
You don't go and raise
your hand and say,
I can do something
about it because I
believe I can
change my situation.
And when people see
that, that's actually
a dangerous perception.
Because they might not
go through this process
where they're trying to figure
out what's beneath the surface.
They're thinking, that person
doesn't take initiative.
I guess they're not
really a leader.
So this process of
looking through it--
as we were doing research
for the book, Jane and I
looked at more than 100
leaders that we interviewed.
And the leaders that
we found were the most
successful-- in their
career, in navigating
across the different cultures
throughout their career,
and were quite senior in
their roles-- they were also
really great at this.
Getting beneath the surface.
Finding out, and being curious
about, not just the behavior,
not just perceptions and
not just their biases,
but really questioning
their assumptions
and getting the real story
and having the conversation
with the people around them
who were a little bit different
than them.
They had those traits, and we
called them fluent leaders.
And we found that
these fluent leaders
were really able
to do this well.
And that's what
we're looking at when
we're looking at successful
global leaders and people who
work with diverse teams.
For Asian Americans, I
think the tips are really
understanding the context.
Understanding the
unwritten rules
of the game that actually are
running that people don't tell
you when you first are
onboarded at Google, that this
is how you succeed here.
This is how you do it.
Understanding that context,
understanding the narratives
that are going on about
Asians and Asian Americans.
Understanding stereotypes.
Knowing that context
really helps you
when you start your
career, when you
start working for
career success.
And also the idea of
flexing, which Erica
shared with you in
the beginning of this.
We call it the art of switching
behaviors and styles in order
to communicate with those
who are different than you.
So basically, can you talk to
the person across the table
from you?
Are you on the same page?
Are you speaking
the same language?
And are you able to
communicate with them?
Do you even know if
you're relating with them?
The onus here is partly on
us, but it's also partly
on the managers, the people who
mentor, the people who develop,
the people in the minority,
Asian Americans included.
As they're looking,
do they flex?
Do they flex to us?
Do we flex to them?
Are we able to
understand our style
so well that we can identify
when we need to flex?
And this is really
important because it's not
about style compliance, which
is the old way of doing it.
You have the dominant
culture, everybody
walks in, everyone
has to act like that.
Women have to wear ties, right.
So we're not talking
about compliance.
We're talking about adapting.
And let me just share an
interesting story about
an executive, Bobbi Silten who
at the time was the president
of the Dockers brand at Levi's.
And Bobbi Silten actually
when people heard her name
thought she was a
man, Caucasian man.
And then she would walk into
the boardroom or the meeting
that she was going
to and people would
be completely taken aback.
First of all, Bobbi
Silten was not a man.
And She was a
petite Asian woman.
And she sat down-- she actually
has a very-- she describes it
as a warm, very open
style, very relational.
She wants to sit down and
start to get to know people.
And she found that this
style, even though it
was very genuine
to who she was, she
had to adapt it a little
bit, because sometimes
the stereotypes that people
had and those judgments
and assessments that people had
about her when they saw her,
she had to counter them.
She had to actually get down to
business right away for people
to take her seriously,
for people to say yeah,
she knows her stuff.
She's an expert.
She belongs here in this room.
She had to kind of
adapt her style and flex
to the environment and the
context that she was in.
Did it change who she was?
No, she was still
the same person.
Still warm, still relational.
But she was very aware
of her environment
and how she needed to behave
in that moment at that time.
So I think that's a challenge,
is that we understand
the contexts in which
we need to flex.
And lastly, also we have to
understand our narrative.
We have to know
this process of what
is beneath the surface
for us so well that we
can tell that story.
And then we have to defend it.
We have to defend
our lunch, right?
We have to tell our story
and stand behind it, and see
if that style actually
offers something of value
that somebody may
not have seen before.
Someone asked me,
OK so if you have
a different kind of
communication style,
is there any way that you
can kind of let people know
that that actually really
works in the situation?
Absolutely.
If you have a style that
is a little bit more quiet,
if you're more collectivistic
and you look to get buy-in
and you're really
effective at that,
if you're a little bit
more emotionally restrained
and you're able to actually
not kneejerk react in crisis
situations, those are all things
that could be really great when
you're managing a team
or you have a project
with a lot of fire drills.
And you're not
reacting and you're
thoughtfully strategic
in the way you manage
your team and your
resources, those
are things that if you know that
come from who you really are
and your values,
and you present it
to somebody, to your manager,
to the people at Google,
people might say, oh my gosh,
I didn't think of it that way.
When I think of a leader, I
think of someone who's strong,
someone who's
charismatic, someone
who's outgoing and extroverted.
And those are very,
very common biases
for what leaders look like.
So when you tell your
story, all of a sudden
we have a different
story for what
another leader looks
like in that context.
And I was just sharing
over lunch with some
[INAUDIBLE] leaders
that people don't always
know what they
haven't seen before.
Joshua Bell, who was
a violinist virtuoso,
did an experiment with
Washington Post many years ago
where he set his violin case
down in the Washington subway
and started playing.
And people didn't
notice him at all.
The funny thing is,
a couple hours went
by-- if you had gone to
see him in Carnegie Hall,
you would have probably
paid about $200 a ticket,
and you would've clapped and you
would've been like, oh my gosh,
I saw Joshua Bell
at Carnegie Hall.
And it would've been this
great experience for you,
and you would have said, he's
the most amazing violinist
I've ever heard.
But when he was in the
subway, nobody knew.
Because we might find a
Picasso in the dumpster.
But we don't know it until
someone puts a frame around it,
a didactic panel,
and auctions it off.
And says, this is the value.
So maybe that's
what we need to do.
We actually need
to frame our value.
We need to share this
narrative with people
so that we can start
this conversation
and we can flex across
the differences.
This is really an art,
it's not a science,
and it requires practice.
I know that all of us have
many situations every day
that we can practice.
And one of the
dimensions-- I just
want to share a dimension,
a couple dimensions,
with you that talk to
understanding differences.
One of the differences
that we noted,
borrowed from
cultural anthropology,
is the difference
of the power gap.
And this is a very critical
dimension to understand,
because we've found that people
who understood the power gap
and knew how to bridge
the power gap actually
were the ones that were the
most effective at flexing.
The power gap is
basically the distance
between the different levels
of hierarchy that exist.
There are formal power gaps.
Every organization
has a hierarchy
between bosses, the
titles and the authority
that's given to people
in different positions.
But there are also
informal power gaps
between people in
different departments--
maybe one's function is
valued over the other-- even
between peers.
There are power gaps between
mentors and mentees, people
who are coaching.
So these levels of hierarchy
are very important,
and that distance
often keeps people
from building relationships.
And there are two extremes
in that power gap,
in the way people
prefer to work.
So we might have someone on the
egalitarian end of the power
gap, where they
have a preference
for actually
minimizing that gap.
They say OK, I'm your boss,
I'm an egalitarian boss,
and I'm your boss
and I have this team.
But I'm not going to exert
my authority over them.
I'm not going to be the boss.
I'm here to guide.
I want to listen to their ideas.
I'm really proud, if I have
an egalitarian preference,
that I have an open door policy.
We hear this a lot.
I expect my team members
to come into my office,
chat, get to know me a little
bit, I'll get to know them.
We'll share ideas.
We'll talk about
questions they have.
They can even challenge me.
They can challenge me.
They can look me
directly in the eye
and say, Audrey, I'm not
sure if that's going to work.
Or I have a problem with that.
Or this is where I
want my career to go.
I'd really like that
stretch assignment.
And if I'm an egalitarian
boss, I'm OK with that.
That doesn't usurp my
respect or my authority.
It's perfectly fine.
I want that.
But if I have a team
member that doesn't
do that when I've invited them
to do that, I might think,
oh my gosh, that person
has no initiative.
That person's a
really hard worker.
They do a really great
job with their teammates,
but they're not leaders.
They're not somebody I can count
on for that stretch assignment.
So if you're the other end, the
other extreme of the power gap
preference, you
might think, I think
about the gap as
something that translates
to respect for authority.
So if you have that preference,
it's a hierarchical preference.
Asian cultures
tend to norm toward
hierarchical preferences.
And there are many other
cultures and groups
that do, as well.
So as someone with a
hierarchical preference,
you don't want to be on the same
level as your boss or someone
who's in authority, because
that's not your level,
and it's not your place
to be at that level.
So that gap represents
your sign of respect.
You're going to let that boss
or that superior call the shots,
give directions, be the person
that speaks up in the meeting.
And depending on how wide that
gap is for you, that's the way
you think it should be.
And so if you have a
boss that says, hey you,
I expect you to come to me.
You might be thinking, that
boss is not a really great boss,
because they're not
doing their job.
They're not being that director.
They're not being that
strong boss that I need.
And the concept for,
again, for a lot of Asians
who have this very strong
hierarchical preference,
is that when they're ready,
their boss will tell them.
They'll tap them on
the shoulder and say,
you're ready for that raise.
You're ready for that promotion.
Or you're ready for
this assignment.
And when that
doesn't happen, they
might get frustrated, because
that's the boss's job.
So what do we do
to close this gap,
and what happens
in the situation?
An egalitarian boss,
how do they flex
to a more hierarchical employee?
I think there's an opportunity
here for that egalitarian boss
to close the gap.
First of all, by
having a conversation.
They might identify again
what's underneath the surface,
and ask that employee, I
noticed these behaviors.
I notice that I never
see in my office.
I know you have a
lot of ideas, but I
don't hear you bring
them up in meetings.
What's going on?
And just really start digging
underneath the surface
to see what are
those motivations
and values that
they can actually
translate into behaviors and
talk about how effective it
is in that context.
And maybe that egalitarian boss,
in order to flex to this style,
might actually give
permission to say,
you know what, you
have great ideas.
I'd like to hear you speak
up in the next meeting.
I'm going to call on you.
Just so you're prepared.
Or, I'm going to put
you on the agenda,
and actually want you to
talk about it this time.
You're going to talk
about this topic.
That's really one way
that they can reach out
to close that gap.
We've talked about this with
several managers before,
and the question that
inevitably comes up
is, wow I don't know if I want
to do all that handholding.
Sounds really high maintenance
that we have to do that.
And I have to say
that, part of flexing
and part of understanding
our own biases
and understanding how to
work across differences
might have these initial
skills, these initial actions
that you have to take that
are a little uncomfortable.
They might feel
like handholding.
But as you coach and as you
mentor these people to do that,
obviously they're going
to get more comfortable
in those situations.
You're actually opening
the door and recognizing
where that plays so
that you can flex.
But if you're the
hierarchical employee,
there's opportunities for
you to flex, too, I think.
For you to really go
through your own process
of looking what's
beneath the surface,
and thinking about what
values do you really have that
are driving those
certain behaviors.
If humility is important
to you, if hierarchy
is important to you,
what does that mean?
Respect for authority?
Does that mean you
can't talk to your boss
in a way that is
questioning or offering
information about yourself
or your accomplishments?
What does that mean to
you to have respect,
and how do you redefine
or recalibrate that
in the environment
that you're in?
So that's one way that you
can flex across the power gap
and to take that
initiative to do that.
And it might be
uncomfortable at first,
but this is where I think
the conversation starts of,
when you're flexing, what
does that look like for you,
and where do you practice it.
And I think you can all go
back to your desks after this
and just make a list of people
that are around you every day--
your boss, your teammates,
maybe people who
report to you, people
within your group-- and say,
what are my power
gap preferences?
Am I egalitarian?
Am I more hierarchical?
Actually personally, I'm more
hierarchical with my superiors,
but with people that I work with
and people who report to me,
I'm much more egalitarian.
So just to know
your own preferences
with how you work with
people, and that awareness,
and then knowing other
people's preferences, too.
And to start flexing
in that way becomes
something really important.
I'm just going to cover
one more dimension.
And this is about communication.
So direct and indirect style.
Direct styles, say what you
mean and mean what you say.
And you might even be
thinking-- if you're
direct-- I hate it when
people beat around the bush.
So passive aggressive.
In direct communication
styles-- you
might relate with this
statement-- people know
what I mean even if I
don't say it explicitly.
I mean I don't want to come
across as rude or harsh
to anyone.
The relationship's
really important,
and I don't want
to say it that way
because it might
hurt their feelings.
So how many people are direct?
How many people relate
with the first one?
Yep.
Direct.
Totally direct.
How many people indirect?
Kind of relate with that?
OK.
And you know,
there's a spectrum.
Just like for the
power gap, there's
a spectrum you fall in between.
I'm totally direct.
Feedback has told me,
my husband has told me.
Very, very, very,
very, very direct.
He's actually pretty indirect.
So sometimes I'm just like,
just say it, just say it.
Say it.
Ask me to marry you.
But direct styles--
it's interesting.
For those direct
communicators, what
do you think about
indirect communicators?
AUDIENCE: Drives me crazy.
AUDREY S. LEE: What's that?
AUDIENCE: Probably
drive me a little crazy.
AUDREY S. LEE: Drives
you a little crazy?
Yeah.
Why?
AUDIENCE: It's just
not [INAUDIBLE] style.
AUDREY S. LEE: It's
not your style.
Right.
What are your impressions-- if
you're a direct communicator,
what are your impressions
of an indirect communicator?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They're
unsure of themselves.
AUDREY S. LEE: They're
unsure of themselves,
right, because why
else can't they say it.
Right?
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: It also seems
like it's more work.
AUDREY S. LEE:
It's so much work.
We can talk afterwards.
Here's the danger of this kind
of assessing and judgments.
Being a direct communicator,
my first thought
is, I'm just honest.
I tell the truth.
And the implication is what?
Indirect communicators
aren't really honest.
They don't really
tell the truth.
That's a pretty dangerous
assessment, I think.
So when I'm thinking this, in
my work in fluent leadership,
in flexing, I have to
catch myself at that moment
and say, don't think that way.
I have to challenge
my assumption
of that truthful,
honest equals to direct.
What about indirect
communicators?
What do you think about when
you encounter someone like me?
Someone like a
direct communicator.
What do you think?
AUDIENCE: They think
that you are rude.
AUDREY S. LEE: I'm so rude.
So rude.
I'm from New York, so I
have sort of an excuse,
but you know.
I'm so rude.
You don't care about people.
I hear that a lot, too.
You're not political.
You don't really know how
to navigate with grace.
You're too blunt.
Too-- I hear too honest, too.
You're just too honest.
So you start to
see how these gaps,
and if you have
people on extremes,
start to really generate
conflict and misunderstanding.
And if you are
indirect [INAUDIBLE],
how do you navigate this?
I think this is a particularly
interesting dimension,
because if you master indirect
and direct, the spectrum
of this-- if you know how
to communicate directly
and you know how to
communicate indirectly,
you can flex anywhere.
And mitigating a message is
just an art in and of itself.
So if you tend to
communicate very directly--
do this on Friday.
I need this on Friday.
You might learn how to mitigate
by asking questions, inviting
people into the conversation,
changing your tone of voice.
Instead of saying,
do this by Friday.
It's like, could you
The use of conditional.
If.
Could.
Would.
Possibly.
If you had time, would
you do this by Friday.
It invites people in.
Mitigating it.
If you're an
indirect communicator
and you find maybe people
don't really know what I mean
or it takes too long for
me to get my point across,
how do you become more direct?
Addressing the
issue specifically.
Talking directly to people.
Sometimes indirect communicators
use third parties to talk.
There's indirect ways
of communicating.
Back in my day, it was leaving
a voicemail at 3 o'clock
in the morning.
It was super indirect, right?
I don't know, now
everything is direct
because everyone is
always communicating.
Also for a lot of--
I hear this a lot
with women and other
minority groups.
The word sorry.
Apologizing.
It mitigates things,
but if you tend
to be an indirect
communicator or people
have that impression
about you, make
sure you watch the
way you apologize.
Because what does
saying I'm sorry mean?
What can it mean to you?
AUDIENCE: That you
will not do it again.
AUDREY S. LEE: That
you won't do it again.
It's your fault.
You did something wrong, right?
But sometimes I'm
sorry just means,
I'm sorry you feel that way.
Or that's maybe a terrible
thing and I'm-- empathy.
Right.
But for a lot of women
and a lot of minorities
who say I'm sorry, people hear
that the wrong way, and it
mitigates it in a way that
the message doesn't become
as strong as you need it to
be when you're making impact.
So really looking
at this dimension,
how you can flex across if
you're whatever preference it
is to the other side
and mastering that,
is going to become
a really great way
to understand the different
styles and how it plays out.
The different
perceptions that happen
at either extreme in
different situations.
So I really want to hear
some of the questions
that you might
have, so I'm going
to pass through
these dimensions.
But I want to say that
they are in the book,
they're covered in the book.
I talk about individualistic
and collectivistic cultures
and style preferences,
as well as
expressive, restrained,
task-oriented and
relationship-oriented
preferences, and some others.
But I want to say for people who
are in the minority population
or find themselves a little
bit different than the dominant
culture, there is a message
for us to really understand
our narrative, as I said,
and understand your values.
Understand what
you have to offer
and how that translates
to the results,
and what you're doing
in the organization.
Knowing your
context and how that
differs from your own
values and your behaviors.
Those unwritten
rules of the game
may be at odds with
how you were raised.
So the behavior that you
need to be exhibiting
may be at odds with how
you're used to behaving.
Think about that.
Be visible and be heard
in the organization.
That develops influence, and
it's really important for you
to do that.
But do it in your own style.
If you go out there,
how are you going
to become visible and be heard?
With your own story, with your
own work, with the own value.
And I know I was just
talking about [INAUDIBLE]
The value of you as a group,
of this ERG as a group, what
is the value to Google?
Be visible and be heard.
Initiate that
dialogue that allows
flexing, that closes
the power gap.
And sometimes it gets
a little tiring, right,
if you're in a minority
group and you're thinking,
I'm always the one
flexing anyway.
I'm always the one reaching out.
Why don't people
reach out to me?
If we think of
ourselves as leaders--
and we need to start thinking
of ourselves as leaders--
the leaders have to
take that initiative.
Because I can't tell
you how uncomfortable
this conversation
is for everybody,
talking about differences.
Nobody's going to initiate--
it's very rare that someone
else will initiate the
conversation with you,
because it's so hard to have.
What are they going
to say to you?
They may not even know.
Build mentor and
sponsor relationships.
This is really important,
that once you--
when you know your
narrative, when
you know your value, when
you understand your story,
you can start building
these relationships
in a very organic way.
And that's important because
you need the sponsors
and you need the
mentors who advise you
and who also influence
on your behalf,
advocate for you on your behalf
when you go for those stretch
assignments and those
promotions and you're
advancing in the organization.
You need that.
And you can't just make these
relationships overnight.
You really have to know how
to communicate and build
those relationships.
For those in the
dominant culture,
I would say that the
role is really important
to understand here, too.
And when I talk to upper
management and other parts
of the organization, the
role for you to flex,
it's more important than ever.
To challenge your unconscious
biases, the judgments that you
make automatically, those
assumptions that you have.
You have to learn how to
flex across the differences,
open the dialogue to people who
seem like they're the other.
And you have to create a fluent
leader culture around you.
And that's your opportunity to
multiply that effect, really
understanding how to create this
culture where you can actually
integrate peoples and understand
the value of people who
are different than you and
integrate that into your work
and into your team.
So that really
requires for you to be
curious to understand what
is beneath the surface,
and to become a fluent leader.
I just want to end
with saying that that
is our opportunity
and our challenge,
to grow the fluent leader
culture here at Google
and to actually make
that second nature.
And it's really hard
to do, but there's so
many ways that we can start
identifying those gaps
and how we can start
flexing across differences.
Thank you so much for letting
me talk a little bit about that.
I'd love to continue the
conversation with you.
You can follow me on Twitter.
I have a hashtag #CeilingStories
that I'm starting.
I would actually love
to hear a little bit
about your experiences
as hopefully we
continue this discussion.
Barriers that you might see.
How you engage with the team
and the organization around you.
And some challenges
that you might see,
and how you've gotten over them
or if they still exist for you.
So I'd love to continue that
conversation with you, too,
beyond just today.
FEMALE SPEAKER: Thank
you so much, Audrey.
AUDREY S. LEE: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]